cyber attacks are frequently making
headlines in today's digital environment
at any time everyone who uses a computer
could become a victim of a cyber attack
there are various sorts of cyber tanks
ranging from phishing to password
attacks
in this video we'll look into one such
attack that is known as botnet
but before we begin if you love watching
tech videos subscribe to our channel and
hit the bell icon never to miss an
update to begin with let's take a look
at some of the famous botanic attacks
the first one is mirai botnet which is a
malicious program designed to attack
vulnerable iot devices and infect them
to form a network of bots
that on command perform basic and medium
level denial of service attacks
then we have the zeus bot
specifically designed for attacking the
system for bank related information and
data
now let's take a look at the agenda for
today's video
firstly we'll understand what is a
botnet
then we'll see how exactly a botnet
works
after that we'll learn some of the
architectures how a botnet works on
in the end we learned how to protect
ourselves from botnet attacks
now let's see what exactly a botnet is
botnet refers to a network of hijacked
interconnected devices that are
installed with malicious codes known as
malware
each of these infected devices are known
as bots the hijack criminal known as
port heidegger remotely controls them
the bots are used to automate large
scale attacks including data theft
server failure malware propagation
and denial of service
attacks now that we know what exactly a
botnet is
let's dive deeper into learning how
botnet works
during the preparation of a botnet
network the first step involves
preparing the botnet army after that the
connection between the botnet army and
the control server is established
and the end the launching of the attack
is done by the bot order
let's understand through our
illustration
firstly we have a bot order that
initiates the attack
according to the control server commands
the devices that are infected with the
malware programs and begins to attack
the infected system
let's see some details regarding the
preparation of the botnet army
the first step is known as the prepping
the botnet army
the first step is creating a botnet is
to infect as many as connected devices
as possible this ensures that there are
enough bots to carry out the attack
this way it creates bots either by
exploiting the security gaps in the
software or websites or using phishing
attacks
they are often deployed through trojan
horses
the next step we have
establishing the connection
once it hacks the device as per previous
step it infects it with the specific
malware that connects the device back to
the control bottom server
a bot holder uses command programming to
drive the bot's actions
and the last step is known as launching
the attack
once infected a bot allows access to
admin level operation like gathering and
stealing of data
reading and rewriting the system data
monitoring user activities performing
denial of service attacks including
other cyber crimes
now let's take a look at the important
architecture the first type is known as
client server model the client server
model is a traditional model that
operates with the help of a command and
control center server
and communication protocols like irc
when the bot order issues a command to
the server it is then relayed to the
client to perform malicious actions
then we have peer-to-peer model
here controlling the infected bots
involves a peer-to-peer network that
relies on a decentralized approach that
is the bots are topological
interconnected
and acts as both cnc servers that is the
server and the client
today hackers adopt this approach to
avoid detection and single point failure
in the end we will see some points on
some counter measure against botnet
attacks
the first step is to have updated
drivers and system updates
after that we should avoid clicking
random pop-ups or links that we often
see on the internet
and lastly having certified antivirus
anti-spyware softwares and firewall
installed into a system will protect
against malware attack
with this we have reached the end of the
video
if you have any questions regarding the
topic you can ask them on the comment
section thank you
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here